when did this company start okay so it
stud I mean they're so often the the
history is kind of like you know we
tried to do something and then event
something else entirely and in 2004 I
co-founded with business and initially
we were trying to do an online store
ourselves we were selling snowboards
online so you were selling snowboards
yeah right so people actually we were
using Yahoo stores back then so oh yeah
yahoo had a store product that program
spear bap they sold that to yahoo yahoo
we wrote it a couple of times so then
became yahoo stores and we used that
and the idea was this was you know my
background is I'm a programmer and I
apprenticed as a programmer which is
something you can do when you're from
Germany and I wanted to get sort of out
out of that a bit I wanted to start a
retail business something else I was
really interested in the book of
manufacturers got some snowboards one of
the seven we wanted to use something off
the shelf and realized there was no
frigging way we could make build the
business we wanted based on office chef
software that was available back in 2004
so over the course of his first season
of sales your place that we've suffered
build ourselves 2004 was right to time
then movie and words came out so yeah
it's fun to play around with and I got
involved very much in Ruby and rails
community
David hammer Hansen 37signals force were
part of founding it absolutely huge
inspiration to us where are they based
in Canada no they are based in Chicago
Oh Chicago right yeah and David is from
Denmark also moved to Chicago van yeah
and that was smells good fun we had a
lot of fun building the technologies or
like reinvigorated my kind of interest
in programming back then and sort of
because of like you know if you want to
go into a full story there there was
again a lot of interest in early Reuben
rails community and a lot of people are
following what what I was doing was part
of a core team and so on of Reuben rails
and so people were saying you know it's
really cool that you guys have this you
it's no devil of a snowboard store but
would you license the software and then
we sort of realized well maybe maybe
helping other people go through this and
building their stores might actually be
a better business and then selling
snowboards and this is sort of how we
pivoted and in 2006 we launched Shopify
sort of taking a lessons from from from
base camp this was again even 2006 soft
as a surface wasn't the term yet so
right people were not charging for
cloud-based software at that time with
the exception of Basecamp and I'm trying
to think of who else
Dropbox hadn't launched yet it was the
idea of offering a service in the cloud
instead of downloading installing
software to a server didn't really exist
or Salesforce yeah it's calling calling
people like I mean if you wanted
software you you had to talk to
salespeople and then there would be no
prices on websites like even even even
just putting a price on the website was
innovative in 2000 before ever even
though that sounds crazy that screen
where you have like here's your three
options and this is the best one for you
yeah that was a true innovation by
37signals absolutely and it's hard to
remember that at this point but ya know
this was all very impressive and it was
so clear that that was the way stuff it
should be so done Internet and then we
wanted to do this for online stores and
so you launch the product at twenty
thirty bucks a month or something to
have a store yeah we had a brief about a
year period where we tried some really
different things because the vvb read
things a bit wrong and wanted to go to a
freemium sort of before everyone else
and so we said no money up front and
it's only a percentage based fee which
was still de nieve really it was it
meant that it cost nothing for people
who didn't end up having any sales and
it cost way too much for people who did
have sales so it took us a while to get
this right but what we settled on was
you know 29:24 dollars now it's down to
fifteen dollars or nine dollars
depending on which IPTS you've heard of
yeah and it's that's that's all you need
to start up